hallo rahel hallo andreas wie geht es
dir
[Musik]
wie geht es dir
mir geht es super und dir
mir geht es auch gut mir geht es auch
gut
stell dir vor anita hat im lotto
gewonnen
was wow aber wer ist schon wieder anita
sie ist die schwester meiner mutter sie
ist meine tante sie ist die schwester
meiner mutter sie ist meine tante stimmt
wahnsinn stimmt wahnsinn
sie ist ein glückspilz
wie viel hat sie gewonnen
sie hat zehn millionen franken gewonnen
das ist viel geld
was würdest du machen wenn du zehn
millionen franken gewinnen würdest
hmmm
also ich würde zuerst meine steuern
bezahlen
dann würde ich mir einen hund kaufen
danach würde ich eine lange reise machen
ich würde mit meinem hund nach
südamerika fliegen
da würde ich am strand liegen und
cocktails trinken da würde ich am strand
liegen und cocktails trinken so toll
da würde ich auch mitkommen
toll da würde ich auch mitkommen
ich würde surfen lernen
ich würde
einen
ich würde jeden tag frisches obst und
fisch essen
und ich würde ganz viele bücher lesen
und ich will
ganz viele bücher lesen
ja ja und ich würde spanisch lernen
so könnte ich mich mit den leuten besser
unterhalten
gute idee eine sprache lernen macht spaß
genau
deshalb lernen wir ja deutsch
hallo lukas die geht's hallo lukas die
geht's hallo vanessa mir geht es gut und
dir
hallo vanessa mir geht es gut und dir
mir auch für ihn ist das geschenk mir
auch für wen ist das geschenk
es ist für meine ältere schwester
sie wird heute 20 jahre alt
sie studiert medizin
die studie
die ziehen
möchte sie ärzten werden möchte sie
ärztin werden
ja genau
was möchtest du werden wenn du groß bist
ich wäre gern polizisten
dann könnte ich diebe jagen und
verhaften
oder astronauten
dann könnte ich mit einer rakete ins
weltall fliegen
ich könnte auf dem mond spazieren
und ich könnte aliens beobachten und
erforschen
das würde sicher viel spaß machen
und du was möchtest du werden wenn du
groß bist
ich wäre gern ein indiana
ich wäre gern ein indianer
dann hätte ich ein pferd dann hätte ich
ein pferd
ich könnte jeden tag reiten
und ich durfte immer draußen sein und im
zelt schlafen
und ich
die immer draußen sein und im zelt
schlafen
das klingt super
vielleicht möchte ich auch eine
indianerin werden
guten morgen julian
guten morgen mehlis es ist schon 10 uhr
du bist eine stunde zu spät guten morgen
julian
guten morgen mehlis es ist schon 10 uhr
du bist eine stunde zu spät ja ich weiß
es tut mir leid
ja ich weiß es tut mir leid
heute morgen viel pech
viel pech
warum was ist passiert warum was ist
passiert
mein wecker hat nicht geklingelt
deshalb
habe ich verschlafen
mein
nicht geklingelt
deshalb habe ich verschlafen
warum hat dein wecker nicht geklingelt
darum hat ein wecker nicht geklingelt
weil ich ihn nicht gestellt habe
ich bin gestern abend vor dem fernseher
eingeschlafen
wärst du doch bloß nicht vor dem
fernseher eingeschlafen
als ich heute morgen aufgewacht bin war
es schon halb neun
ich habe mich schnell angezogen
und bin aus dem haus gerannt
leider habe ich mein
rucksack vergessen deshalb musste ich
noch einmal zurück laufen
leider habe ich mein
vergessen deshalb musste ich noch einmal
zurück laufen
als ich dann endlich bei der
bushaltestelle war ist mir der bus vor
der nase weggefahren
als ich dann endlich bei der
bushaltestelle war ist mir der bus vor
der nase weggefahren
o hättest du doch bloß deinen rucksack
nicht vergessen
ja wenn ich meinen rucksack nicht
vergessen hätte dann hätte ich den bus
nicht verpasst
ja wenn ich meinen rucksack nicht
vergessen hätte dann hätte ich den bus
nicht verpasst
und was hast du dann gemacht
und was hast du dann gemacht ich bin
wieder nach hause gerannt
ich bin wieder nach hause gerannt
und habe mein velo aus der garage geholt
dann bin ich mit dem velo ins büro
gefahren
oh du armer das ist wirklich dumm
gelaufen
ja hätte ich doch bloß nur von anfang an
das velo genommen
hast du eine frage schreibt eine frage
in die kommentare
wir werden sie beantworten
möchtest du gratis online deutsch lernen
mehr als 200 video lektionen abonniere
unseren kanal